[Music]
yeah I want to talk to you about what
does automated machine learning and why
would we want it and what's the current
state of the art stuff none of this is
actually gonna be my research but I hope
I can give you like a good overview of
what's happening so first why do we want
automatic machine learning so my
personal goal is to make machine
learning accessible to everybody ideally
you shouldn't need to like read a book
or do even like degree in machine
learning or data science to apply
machine learning to a problem
unfortunately that's not really where we
are it's really very important right now
with the tools we have it's really
important to have a really good
understanding of what's going on on a
technical side to make use of any
machine learning so and I want to build
better tools that can bridge this gap a
little bit so what are the issues that
are with that we have with current tools
so for example second learn because
that's the tool I work on most but it's
similar before other tools so what are
the issues that you face as a beginner
if you want to start with machine
learning using cycle or so I said none
of this will be my work but the problems
that you get are probably my work at
least in part so one of the problems is
there's a lot of different algorithms
out there you need to first formulate
your problem as machine learning a
problem then you need to pick the right
model so a couple of years ago I made
this ridiculous flowchart of how to
approach machine learning problem
I was actually meant as a joke but a lot
of people really liked it because it
gave them some place to start from some
guidance into how to enter a machine
learning problem and so which shows how
difficult is this for a beginner so the
idea was to tell people a bit what model
is appropriate for what task but even if
you know this then there's the problem
which is how do you tune this model to
work well for your dataset and for your
problem each of these models come with
many many type of parameters and so I
could learn they're actually some of
them are intrinsic to the model
some of them are for the optimization
some of them are just some special use
cases if you look at here this is a
support vector machine which usually has
like parameters or kernel kernel
parameters and regularization but if you
look at what it actually has it has like
ten and they're maybe not as obvious
what they are and so there's an
intrinsic problem in tuning algorithm
but there's also a problem of how is
this exposed to the user so if you're
new to machine learning this can be
quite overwhelming quite challenging to
apply to your problem another problem is
with pre-processing so second learn is
designed in a way that you have to do
everything explicitly if you look at
other toolboxes for example in our tools
are more sort of automatic and they try
to do some pre-processing for you since
I could learn everything is sort of the
plane algorithm more or less like it is
published in a sense so which means if
you have a real data set you need to
take care of the encoding of categorical
variables or other variables you need to
make sure that there's no missing values
you need to make sure that the data is
on a certain scale that makes sense for
your model and so here you see what you
would need to do to apply a support
vector machine on a standard data set
yeah
encoding categoricals imputation scaling
and so the reason ii learn does it this
way is to give the user a lot of control
but on the other hand if you don't do
this things will either work very badly
or break and so again you need a lot of
domain knowledge to know what do I
actually need to do to my data before I
can apply machine learning model and
this is another like some wing stone for
a beginner so what I would like to have
instead is I just want to have an
automatic model say an auto classifier
that I can fit on any any data and it'll
just keep it writing and provide me with
better and better models over time so if
I wait longer again longer get better
and better models and it just trying to
do Python for me this is in contrast to
like sort of having to figure out
everything by myself and then
unit there's actually a library out
there called Auto SK learner's that's
something like this and there's also
several commercial services to do
something like this there's like I think
one is by h2o and one is pied-a-terre
robot and maybe other companies have
other things like this but there's not
really a good framework to do this right
now open source or commercial I would
say now obviously I want an open source
one so what do we need to do to get
there
there are several pieces to this the
arguably simple
well maybe simplest piece is to automate
the search procedure let's say you know
what model you want to use say you want
to use a support vector machine or a
neural network or a random forest and
you want to tune just the parameters of
this model so there's a large body of
work on how to do this this is basically
given a particular search space and
measure that you will optimize say
accuracy how can I find the best setting
of these parameters so I'll talkin adapt
some more about this later the second
part is not only select the parameters
of the model but also select the
pipeline and sorry
not just the parameters could also
select the model so possibly II say I
wanted a support vector machine on this
problem random forests on this problem
and so on and one step further is
selecting actually the complete pipeline
how do you extract features how do you
pre-process the data how do you do every
single step that is required from the
raw data and so you have sort of search
moving parameter searching over model
from then searching over pipelines as
more it's hundred harder problems so how
are we gonna approach this
so the first thing you need to do is
even for the first step is you need to
formalize the search space so you need
to say what are the models and
parameters I want to search over and
this already is kind of tricky so
there's the mixture of discrete and
continuous parameters you might want to
search over
there's conditional parameters for
example in neural network you have to
give the size of every layer but like
the size of the second hidden layer only
matters if you actually have two hidden
layers so the importance of one
parameters or the existence of one
parameter is actually dependent on what
the other parameters are set to so that
makes a search a little bit tricky
because a space is sort of pre shaped
and then it has a question of how do you
want to search over these pipelines do
you say oh I'm always gonna do scaling
and imputation and then feature
selection and this or am I just gonna
allow out early computation graphs and
that sort of these choices make a real
big difference and how the system will
work in the end and then also you need
to sort of figure out a way how to what
to include in a search space so let's
say oh I'm gonna search over everything
that's possible in scikit-learn
or everything that's an R or everything
that's in my car and but the question is
is that a good approach but also an
gather say and say oh I'm always just
gonna use a random for it's probably
gonna work out fine and so the question
is what is the right search space and
what are the right from the ranges to
search over so once you've done that you
need to figure out a search method so
now let's say you have this relatively
complex leash a pretty big search space
that contains all the parameters and all
the pipeline's and all the models and
now we need to search over this so the
search is usually for something like
cross we need accuracy so this this is
sort of a global optimization problem
because there's there's very little that
we know about this function
how well is that stress-related accuracy
do as a function of the parameters or
the pipeline you can certainly not
compute a derivative of it or and it's
pretty sure it's not convex so you just
need to have some search function can
work with this very complex function on
this very big space so the first and one
of the most commonly used methods is
just exhaustive search search all
possible combinations also called great
search this works reasonably well if you
fix most of the steps and say oh I just
want to search the parameters of the
random force or the parameters of the
SVM if you want to search over many
different pre-processing steps many
different models the search space
becomes exponentially larger with each
step that you add basically and this
quickly becomes infeasible another
problem is that there's you can't really
stop this at if you say you run out of
time because you're scanning the space
in like a very regular manner that means
you basically have to do wait to the end
before you get any reasonable result so
that's good if you have like very small
search space but otherwise it's actually
not a very good strategy
another straightforward method is just
randomly sample from the space that you
have somewhat surprisingly this is
actually much better already in
particular if you work on spaces that
are continuous and discrete sampling
from continuous parameter spaces instead
of defining a grid makes the search much
more efficient also a randomized search
you can stop at any point you can just
say okay now I searched enough and I
take just the best result I have so far
or if you have more budget you can keep
searching if you define a grid and in
the end you got some result but you say
oh I actually have more computational
budget it's very hard to spend this
budget like in an obvious manner
yeah so so this works already much
better it's actually it has a cool paper
by a Baxter on Ben Joe from oh I don't
know a couple years ago that talks about
how this randomized search consistently
beats grid search if you have continuous
parameters and if you're interested in
this kind of stuff you should read it so
the next kind of method that is one step
in complexity up is what's called page
optimization or sequential model based
optimization SMV oh so here the idea is
that well we have this very expensive to
evaluate function that tryna model and
evaluated using cross-validation and we
have no structure in the space but we
want to optimize it so the idea here is
that you build a model you have this
function like translated accuracy given
the observations that you have so far
and you built this model using a
function that sort of that's smooth or
at least of differentiable and then you
optimize this function using some
off-the-shelf optimizer so um a common
approach to this is use the Gaussian
process use a Gaussian process to model
all the values of accuracy that you
observed so far as a function of the
parameters and then run like I'll BFGS
or something like this on the Gaussian
process to find a minimum and evaluating
the Gaussian process or whatever
parameterize function you have that you
fit to the model to the data is much
much easier and much much faster than
trying to retrain a model so I'm gonna
run through a brief example here so
let's say we have a model with one
continuous parameter which is on the x
axis and accuracy or whatever you want
optimize is on the y axis and so the
truth the true dependence of the
accuracy on the parameter is the but the
dashed red line and so we start off by
trying randomly one parameter
I don't never know sorry I don't have a
pointer I think so and we so we try
something like minus 0.4 or something
and we observe an outcome and so what
we're doing now is we try to build a
function that models this outcome right
now we only have one data point so
there's not a lot of information so we
basically build a constant function
which is the purple function you can see
a purple line and then there's some
standard deviation now we look at what
is the next best point to try and the
next point we want to try is one that is
gotta be good but also that gives us
more information about how the function
looks like so we don't necessarily want
to find the highest point that we have
or sorry we're minimizing find the
lowest point but we want to find the
point that is low but also that it gives
us new information you can use that
using what's called the lower confidence
bound which basically looks at the lower
contour of the standard deviation so we
look at the lower contour of the
standard deviation of the purple thing
and this is this green function you see
at the bottom we so this we now have we
have the derivative we could compute
anything we want about this so we
minimize this minimizing this is easy
and we find the minimum is this is here
on this border so now we can train our
model using this parameter setting and
we observe another outcome which is the
second panel up there now we have two
data points we can retrain the model
which you gives as a new purple model of
what the function looks like
which gives us a new lower confidence
bound here which we can minimize again
efficiently which gives us a new
proposal point and we can go on and on
so in this process we try iteratively
new points that are proposed using this
lower confidence bound and we get a more
more accurate model of the original
function as you can see the purple model
is will be a very good model of the
function around the minimum we're only
interested in a minimum of the function
we're not interested in modeling the
whole function we just want to find a
minimum so this is a this strategy is
pretty general here to some of the
Gaussian process you can basically use
any other function you like people try
to like to use random first two and this
works better than random search usually
but not by a lot so this is if you know
global optimization is the np-hard
optimization problem so there's not that
many guarantees you can have how well
this performs an actual problem yes so
there's a couple of common models that
people like to use as I mentioned
there's Gaussian processes random
forests which is with an implementation
called smack and then there's some
nonparametric method that's a bit older
and so they all have different strengths
the weaknesses actually I don't want to
go into it details too much well maybe
so the Gaussian process is basically
what basically everybody uses in the
literature but it can't really work with
discrete parameters which is not great
for what we want to do because we want
to optimize between different models say
between using a random forest and neural
network that's the discrete parameter
Gaussian process is country deal well
with that it's really it's not that
scalable to many many evaluations so if
your search space is big you probably
need to have a lot of data points and
then the Gaussian process becomes slow
and it's a little unclear how to handle
conditional parameters so for example at
the size of the enth layer only matters
if you have n layers in your network but
there's many implementations many of
them very high quality and you only need
to lose for each parameter that's
continuous you only need to specify the
bounds random forests are sort of more
flexible because they're tree based
methods and they can deal with the
screed parameters you can deal with
conditional parameters they're scalable
but there's only like one implementation
out there there's only one group working
on it unfortunately
if you want to specify the continuous
parameters you need to specify a prior
and then the nonparametric model is like
it's basically there was one person
working on it and he created a start-up
and so but it works actually quite well
all right so this is now let's say we
have to find a search space and now we
have sort of a smart method to search
over it that would mean that basically
whenever we encounter a new machine
lying problem we have this giant search
space and we have a smart search method
and now we're going to try out all the
different things that we can and we
explore using this like Bayesian
optimization that's that really how
human expert would approach this human
expert would use prior knowledge so how
are you gonna do that so using prior
knowledge for this automatic machine
learning is what's called meta learning
or there's some which is some form of
warm starting the search so instead of
starting a search from scratch each time
where we want to build up a knowledge
base off what models perform well and
use this knowledge in the future so the
way that meta learning is usually
formulated is you start off with some
data set if you run this optimization
process on it that we just described
which probably takes like quite a while
and but then again it spits out a good
model so all right so we did that once
then we take another data set and
another data set and we learn this
optimization this optimization takes
quite a while but in the end we find
some good models but now we want to
encode this into a model that so that we
can use this as product prior knowledge
the way we do this is that we extract
what's called meta features from the
data set so these are properties of the
data set for example how many samples
are there how many features are there
are they sparse what are the sanity
how many classes that are there and so
on so properties that describe the data
set like one feature vector per data set
and then we can learn machine learning
model that basically recommends based on
this meta features what algorithms and
parameter to use so we're trying to
predict from the meta features a new
pipeline and parameter settings like you
can see how this might work with nearest
neighbors let's say we find the problem
that we saw that's most similar and
we're just gonna apply the same model
that we found there this will definitely
be better than just starting to search
from scratch
yeah and so in general if you have a new
data set you all you're gonna put you
can extract the meta features you apply
your machine learning model your meta
model and spits out some parameters and
this now is much much faster and running
the search this is just extracting the
features and then running the model to
predict not doing this search over this
big space using Bayesian optimization or
whatever yeah which brings us to the
problem okay what are these meta
features so I already listed a couple of
them already this is actually so quite a
local problem one one meta feature it
actually works very well is so called
landmark features which are how well
this machine learning model acts to on
this problem for example you can compute
very quickly how well do decision stamps
work on this problem how well this
lynnium want to work on this problem how
well does they base work on this model
on this problem and use this as as
length works to figure out how well
other models will work but is this
really something that least needs like a
lot more work so
yeah I want to talk about a little more
now what are the existing approaches out
there mostly from more systems of
software perspective there's like a
giant amount of research out there and
there's like a lot of papers being
published a each conference we're
hearing conference but I'm one more
focus on the practical aspects because
they actually want to solve problems so
I think the best contender so far is
what's called Auto SK learn there's a
few friends of mine from Freiburg just
this model and it's on github and you
can download it and try it out and
basically what it does is implements one
version of this auto classifier and this
has a fixed pipeline I think it always
does what not include being imputation
scaling feature selection future
transformation and then a model so it's
like five or six steps and then they
search overall basically everything it's
this I could learn for each of these
steps or everything that makes sense so
they have and they have a hand-tuned
search space of what kind of parameter
settings to search over they use the
random force for their for the search
and then they also have metal learning
mathematical learning they use is just
nearest neighbor so they you do nearest
neighbor on the meta features find a
model for that and then start to search
from this so they do warm starting of
their search using my head learning
related all the project is auto wake up
it does something very similar only it
just searches for marbles so there's no
pipeline there's just it tries out
different models and the parameters
obviously you can use it with both smack
which is a tree based method and with a
nonparametric method it doesn't do any
metal learning though and yeah it
doesn't do any pre-processing so this
just searches over models and parameters
and obviously it serves over the ones
that ran back out
yeah there's also hyperope SK learn
which tries to do something similar to
other SK learn only it doesn't do
pipelines and it's not maintained
anymore so I really miss my in time life
another one that's quite interesting is
from another of mine from Japan it's
called tip out so this this actually
quite a different approach this doesn't
use Bayesian optimization and doesn't so
it doesn't use the centered search it
uses genetic programming this is
confusing because the ones used to
costume processes the others use generic
programming and most people try to use
these acronyms GP but they are
completely different so this uses
genetic programming to build a brewery
complex pipelines and arbitrary complex
computation graphs to optimize the
pipeline the parameters and everything
basically and I don't think they
actually need to specify search space
for this they basically they just need
to specify two operators of how it's
possible to combine things and haven't
really seen a good comparison on how
well this works but that at least from a
conceptual perspective it's quite quite
interesting so these are actually the
only package does that try to do all of
these things that I talked about and
only one of them does method learning so
there's only yeah so there's not a lot
metal learning out there it's like
practical there's a couple of packages
that's just do to search part and that's
the very important part so I want to
talk about this a little bit more detail
soon most of these are for Gaussian
processes there's one but it from your
lab that basically like I think they
proposed this approach or at least a
champion bid for quite a while
it's called spearmint and was developed
for neural networks and as I think was
used quite intensively in like Neela for
community but then they made a company
out of it and a company got bought by
Twitter and now this was not maintained
anymore and then they all portray
and went to Google I think so okay
pretty cool
another implementation of caution Pugh
says based search is a jeep I opted it's
from the group off oh my god Lawrence so
he's like a God with GPS so this is
really solid stuff that's what it's
built on Jeep high which is there
Gaussian process libraries which is
probably the Gaussian process library
and so it also did pretty well in
benchmark except that I ran so it's
pretty cool
there's also suck it up to Mize which is
done by my friends that also just I
could learn this actually tries to
implement all kind of different
optimization methods so it has Gaussian
process based stuff has this random
force based stuff at Radian boosting
randomized search and so on and yeah and
so that's sort of what these libraries
are all they do search that a global
optimization in arbitrary search spaces
so these are helpful building blocks for
doing automatic ml but they don't
specify any of the parameter ranges so
you need to do a lot of work to actually
use them for our medic machine learning
so I want to show some brief benchmarks
and how these methods compare so this is
actually like really silly benchmark
because the so this is just this is just
doing parameter search and global
optimization for very simple problems so
the first two are actually like
artificial global optimization problems
in I think they are both in like two
dimensions so they're very small and
then there's logistic regression linear
discriminant SVM and so this is from a
paper from the group that created
spearmint they proposed the thing that's
a deep neural network it's on the right
and so that one wins always but you can
see that there's
basically the GPS do very well on these
small low dimensional functions they're
all but mostly smooth and smack and TP
it do reasonably well I also have this
is actually done by someone that does
that works on socket optimize and FAQ it
optimize doesn't win so I trust this a
lot more so they say chip I opted action
does the best he ran it over I don't
know ten different benchmark data sets
these are all very small data sets and
they're not really so this is only
benchmarking the search part not the
whole Auto mouth part and so yeah the
defy opt is best and some of the second
optimized ones to also pretty well but
actually most of them do relatively well
and he published a benchmark and the
code and he published a docker container
to run the benchmark and so I like him a
lot so alright think it's enough
benchmarks so there's really well one
interesting match Marcus has said if an
interesting criticism to it so you might
not be so this is a comparison of some
of the algorithms I describes Mac ran so
this is doing this benchmark for doing
the complete automatic machine learning
thing like building a new pipeline and
it compares smack TPE and random search
and just using a random forest hyper
band which is what I proposed which is a
really cool method but I'm not going to
talk about it and then random search 2x
and interesting years so random search
to ax basically means we just runs a
random search but we run it on two
computers in parallel and if you look at
this so I mean basically there's two
criticisms in here one is oh and to wait
true to read this is this is average
rank over many data sets over a number
of evaluations so you start on left and
you give it more and more time
to compute and the one that is lowest is
the winner right now that gives you the
best model and so there's two criticisms
in here one is the random force base
line it's pretty good it's not like at
least in the for quite a while
it it beats some of the other models
which means just running a random force
instead of running automatic machine
learning it's a pretty good idea
always works that's the other criticism
is that basically all the fancy methods
that people publish on particularly the
one that they publish on here the hyper
band they're all contained between doing
random random search and doing random
search on two computers at the same time
so that means they're not that they're
worse than twice or in less than twice
as fast as a random search the good
thing about random searches it's
embarrassing in parallel you can just
run on a cluster because they're
completely independent and so you can
run on the cluster that's as big as you
like so and people poured hundreds and
hundreds of hours into optimizing some
fancy methods ninjas in Bayesian
optimization but they not even the
factor of two better than doing the
stupidest thing possible so but they're
still somewhat better so maybe it's
still worse today and you know so that's
there was an interesting observation
soon I have like five four minutes I
think so I want to talk about a little
bit of what we need to do to push this
forward says far as I said there's like
there are some implementations are
already out there but not that many and
they're not that great they're mostly
liked research quality I mean I love
what the people did but I think they are
so lot to do so one of the things that
has been very little research on is
defying the search space of models so
that's actually in practice it's
very important of course you don't want
to try every possible combination and
it's something where we could put expert
knowledge in the system also there's not
really a lot of research on how to
define the pipeline search space what
are the necessary steps do you need to
include feature selection you need to
include feature extraction and so on and
usually most of the method that I showed
you implement it either everything
together or they implement just the
optimization method and so having a
clean separation of these pieces and
working on these pieces separately will
also how both much pair systems and so
yeah we also need to exploit prime know
much better because right now it's not
the only implementation and I know of
uses one nearest neighbor and it's not
very usable and also there's papers that
take run time and consideration but any
none of the implementations that I know
do so what I mean by this is if you have
two models one is really quick and one
takes a long time they're nearly as good
you want to run a quick model and not
the neural network that trains for two
weeks unless you already spend a lot of
time and now you want to really get the
last bit so that you need to take into
consideration how well you think the
model will do compared to how long it
might take and yeah there's a lot of
research on this but not really any
implementations there's also a lot of
cool stuff on that data subsampling but
again it's mostly research quality so in
last two minutes I want to talk about
some criticisms of this automatic
because I mean there's a lot of people
are excited about automating machine
learning there's also a lot of people
not as excited about it and I'm kinda
excited cautiously excited maybe so one
of them is I said that's more criticism
off to the research on page optimization
is the random search works well and
problems np-hard so maybe don't spend
too much time on trying to do this and
so we could say well okay I'm just gonna
do random search now and don't bother
bother or if I say ok one point five
times speed ups actually important
well maybe use one of these methods but
it doesn't mean awesome Allah is not
useful it just means that maybe the
search part is not the most important
part already alluded to is do really to
try a hundred classifiers I think make
the system said search of our
classifiers maybe that I think automaker
has over a hundred I don't know how many
cycads autocycle learn has maybe like
twenty or thirty actually an average
gradient boosting decision trees always
win
so do we actually get many models and
just learning a random forest is also a
good baseline so how many models so we
actually need and do we actually need
complex pipelines like this genetic
programming that builds arbitrary
complex systems do we really need that
it's not really clear now that criticism
is people say oh well this will spit out
a system some system that makes
predictions but I can't actually inspect
it in particular the thing that Otto SK
learn does is it actually builds an
ensemble so it builds it does a search
it finds a couple of good models and
then averages all of them because if you
average a bunch of good models it's
always going to get a little bit better
and so you go this might build very
complex prime-minister impossible to
understand and so I think that's a valid
criticism too but it's only you need to
make you need to make a decision whether
the yeah do I need my system to be
interpretable or not and I think that's
probably a decision you need to make
very early in your machine learning
process or new data science process if
you do add click prediction maybe it's
enough to make the right prediction
maybe if you listen to the keynote you
think it's not enough to make the right
panel discussion it's not enough to make
the right prediction understand what's
going on but you should think about am i
okay with a black box model yes or no if
no don't do it ought to make machine
learning probably or make sure to search
spaces so that anything that comes out
of it it's useful for you and one of my
favorite criticisms is it's making it
too easy what I love about this else all
right I got this criticism for
scikit-learn people told me you make
machine learning too easy now everybody
can use it it was like really well thank
you and I mean there's definitely a risk
in providing tools and make giving
people just enough tools to be dangerous
you need to so you need to know what
you're doing like for example how to
validate models how to Authority models
at least to some degree
and I think actually automating more
will allow more of the framework to be
automated light the validation
procedures and so on so giving a
framework that does everything
automatically gives more control to the
program and so makes abusing it a little
bit harder so you can build in more
safety mechanisms actually another
criticism but I didn't put on the slides
maybe because I think it's to ballot is
this is only like 20% of what the data
scientists does like if you do look at
any survey of what a data scientists do
oh thanks
they spent very little of their time on
model building and all of your time on
data collection data pre-processing and
so maybe we just saved data scientist
ten percent of the time when we if we
solve this perfectly so okay but maybe
the other part is too hard to automate
I'm not sure okay I posted two slides
you can look at what here all there's
papers and stuff so for if you're new to
machine learning you can also buy my
book because it explains all the hard
parts in an easy way
okay thanks
I think I went slightly over and have
like two or three minutes for questions
does this
yeah oh yeah as you leave make sure you
fill out or put the colored papers in
the basket to say how you like the talk
there's also office hours after the talk
and the room down the the hallway if you
want to ask Andres and some questions
okay second I can ask my question now
okay so thanks for the taco is good
I was just wondering sighs so you
discuss a couple several different
approaches and I assuming when he
applied the same several approaches to
the same data set they'll often give not
exactly the same models or not exactly
the same parameters how much would he
say they tend to agree with each other
in terms of interpretability like is it
the case that two different approaches
will give a model that makes sense to
everyone
or will they result in two different
models that can predict the same data
set but gave like contradictory
interpretations sorry you mean the
different automatic machine laying
frameworks yeah yeah there's only one I
mean the only one that I know that I can
download and reasonably run is
autoscaler right but wait but these
these often take like these often like
somebody's much talked about they often
have like randomized approaches to the
kind of crack models right yes so if you
run them over and over again do they
tend to be consistent with the models
that they know okay and I mean that's
that's why they ensemble multiple models
that are doing reasonably well
hundreds other questions hi thanks for
your talk today I was wondering if there
are any tools you might recommend or
point me to or that you're aware of for
automating the process of determining
which features to extract in the in the
process of determining what data you
actually feed into an ml model so you're
asking about the other 80% of the actual
hard parts and I don't know there's some
work on data cleaning most linear
database literature I don't know of any
work on automated feature extraction in
this framework or you could say all of
deep learning is that so
like an interpretive way to extract
features not that not really I don't I'm
not really aware of anything if anyone
knows any please sending it in my way
there are things like trying to derive
rules from the data for data cleaning
but that's the most I know but it's very
hard to benchmark so there's no
benchmark for this it's not clear what a
benchmark for this would look like and
so that makes it very hard to do
research on it and there are questions
what over there when you're building
lots of models for the same data are
there ever opportunities for something
like dynamic programming where you can
reuse some of the earlier computation
results yes the thing is that's probably
depending on how you built it it might
be hard to do like if you do a grid
search with so I could learn and will
actually
happen depending on how you write this
the problem is if you change a
pre-processing step like if you change
the scaling of your data you probably
need to rerun everything even if you
build a random course that would be
independent of the scaling figuring out
that you don't actually need to rebuild
your random forest on differently scaled
data is something that I don't think
anyone has build a system that can do
that
[Music]